herzlich willkommen mein name ist
bastian bender hat ich schreibe für die
faz über digitales und gaming und ich
bin im moment da wo alle gamer diese
woche hin wollen nämlich in köln auf der
gamescom
ja und jetzt bin ich da wo alle gamer in
diesem jahr leider sein müssen nämlich
zu hause
die gamescom findet in diesem jahr nur
digital statt draußen des corona
deshalb entfällt das traditionelle
zusammentreffen der gamer szene jedes
jahr in köln geht leider dieses jahr
nicht trotzdem haben sich die
veranstalter aber alle mühe gegeben um
auch im digitalen eine gute messe zu
machen es gibt ein vollgepacktes
programm mit allerlei video live streams
es gibt online demos und wir zeigen euch
in diesem video was die messe für euch
bringt welche spiele neu sind was die
themen sind die ikonier bewegen und vor
allem wie sie funktioniert also die an
die inhalte drankommen
[Musik]
wichtig sind für messebesucher vor allem
drei anlaufpunkte gamescom steam und die
in die arena die gamescom ist das
zentrale content habt der gamescom
da werden alle video live streams alles
und alles was es an offiziellen messe
programm gibt verlinkt und können da
angeguckt werden
auf steam soll das zocken stattfinden
also alles wofür man eigentlich bisher
nach köln gekommen ist sich stunden
langen schlangen gestellt hatten sich
durch überfüllte messe heim gekämpft
dann das ganze soll jetzt auf steam
stattfinden
es gibt auf steam ein extra gamescom
bereich wo man sich eine ganze menge
demos runterladen kann von spielen die
auf der messe vorgestellt werden
und naja die wartezeit am stand die man
vorher in der schlange verbracht haben
die wartet man jetzt halt darauf dass
die demo endlich unternehmen
[Musik]
das dritte ist die in die arena buß das
ist quasi die digitale version der indie
games messe halle die auf der gamescom
ja eine ganz lange tradition hat die
indie entwickler haben sich eigentlich
die kreativste umsetzung des digitalen
konzept überlegt sie bieten nämlich an
dass man sich durch die virtuelle messe
halle durchspielen können das heißt wir
haben einen online browsergame
geschaffen wo man tatsächlich mit einem
avatar durch die messehalle durchlaufen
kann nur dass die messehalle eben nicht
aussieht wie eine messehalle sondern ja
wie ein pg also jedenfalls das ist ein
unheimlich kreativ gestaltete stände und
man fühlt sich eigentlich als wenn man
irgendein rollenspiel
man kann mit verschiedenen leuten die
man da trifft also dann laufen würde ich
auch messebesucher durch man kann sich
allerlei trailer angucken und man kann
das ganze auch einfach nur genießen
aber was gibt es denn für spiele die
ganz bekannten spiele die jetzt auf der
gamescom mittelpunkt stehen sind ja
eigentlich schon bekannt unter anderem
gibt es ein neues assassin's creed
assassin's creed walhalla
[Musik]
sie sind herzlos
gottlose bat darin dieses bringt die
übliche schleich und kampf action der
assassinen bruderschaft im ewigen
jahrhundertelangen wettstreit mit dem
templerorden diesmal in eine wikinger
welt
dann gibt es natürlich wie jedes jahr
ein neues fifa fifa 21 wartet darauf
dass man das auch der coach sorgt und
sich sämtliche programme holt wie man
sie holen kann im fußball
und dann gibt es natürlich noch
cyberpunk 20 77 über das wir im letzten
jahr schon gesprochen haben was
eigentlich früher herauskommen sollte da
noch mal wegen kroner verschoben wurde
und jetzt endlich im november kommen
sollte hat auf der gamescom dieses jahr
den award als bestes playstation spiel
bekommen
und ja hoffentlich kommt im november
dann raus großartiges rollenspiel
wahrscheinlich es ist nämlich von den
machern von the witcher 3
aber es gibt ja nicht nur mainstream
spiele was mich zum beispiel gestern in
der opening night am meisten zum lachen
gebracht dann ist das hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es gibt eine neue version von rage
constructor kennt ihr vielleicht ist
eine relativ physikalische akkurate
simulation davon brücken zu bauen über
die dann trucks und autos darüber fahren
müssen und man hofft dass die brücke
nicht zusammenfällt
aber davon gibt es jetzt eine neue
version und zwar wirklich constructor
the walking dead
dieser trailer wurde gestern nachmittag
gezeigt
die fans von etwas außergewöhnlichen
rollenspielen gibt es in diesem jahr
level 12
das ist ein horror spiel aber in einem
total süß gestalteten setting das ist
dieses jahr zum besten nintendos switch
game gewählt worden
und es zeigt dass das spiel was vor drei
jahren mal als mein verein ist glaube
ich hier mal als indie game gestartet
ist jetzt durchaus ziemlich groß werden
kann und viele fans
[Musik]
im gaming gibt es genauso wie bei filmen
das anerkannte prinzip wenn man einmal
eine marke hat macht man einfach so
lange sequels bis irgendwann wirklich
keiner mehr geld dafür ausgeben
das problem hat star wars nicht und
deshalb gibt es in diesem jahr ganze
drei neue star wars spiel auf der
gamescom als erstes relativ klassisch
star wars poker
wenn gauck ist
es ist ein weltweiter flugsimulator wo
man viele missionen im star wars
universum absolvieren kann das ganze ist
thematisch oder eine geschichte gesetz
nach episode 6 also nach die rückkehr
der jedi das spiel wurde zum best action
game gewählt
dann gibt's von star wars her aber auch
die kleine süße edition nämlich lego
star wars gab es auch schon eine ganze
menge spiele von davon gibt es jetzt ein
neues die kollegen von lego legen die
skywalker sager auf das heißt man spielt
sich durch alle star wars episoden
natürlich in süßen lego setting und mit
dem typischen lego star wars humor und
verfolgt die geschichte von luke
skywalker würdig stärken so viel steht
fest
er will von der dunklen seite der junge
skywalker geworden ist
[Musik]
hilf mir obi wan kenobi sagt meine
letzte hoffnung dahin und passt es dass
aller coolste wie ich finde
gibt es ein anderes spiel was ist so in
dieser form noch nicht haben nämlich
einen star wars im sims ist glaube ich
die bekannteste spieler marke überhaupt
eine lebenssimulation wo man mit seinen
sims ja das leben lebt und ihnen für
ihre häuser wollte und so weiter und das
ganze kam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber am ende bleibt die frage was wird
aus der gamescom wird sie nächstes jahr
überhaupt wieder stattfinden oder ist
das digitale format einfach total
ausreichen
das wird sich dieses jahr zeigen und
einer aus der branche der sich damit
auskennt meint die gamescom kann
tatsächlich zu einem hybriden format
werden und aus diesen corona ja lernen
ich glaube es ist eine gute alternative
was wir gerade sie ist ja produzieren
für 2020 aber jeder mit dem ich
gesprochen habe egal ob es jetzt
praktisch der mitarbeiter ist ja
normalerweise den messestand baut und
jetzt das studio gebaut hat oder ob sie
in fenster ist der auf digitalem wege
mit seinem fenster kommuniziert stadt
eben physisch auf der gamescom
jeder wünscht sich die rückkehr war
einfach die der physische kontakt da der
der wirkliche austausch noch mal eine
ganz andere komponente eben ist ob das
digitale format angenommen wird bleibt
abzuwarten mehr publikum können die
veranstalter damit aber auf jeden fall
erreichen und vor allem auch publikum
auf der ganzen welt das muss keiner nach
köln fahren also wir werden sehen wie es
mit der gamescom weitergehen wir sehen
uns nächstes jahr vielleicht oder auch
hoffentlich wieder vor ort in köln
und bis dahin wünschen wir euch erstmal
groß
[Musik]